feeding frenzy inside the story of wet
tech we invite you to phone us with your
questions and comments
[Music]
William Sternberg co-author of feeding
frenzy the inside story of wet tech as a
result of wet tech any lasting
impressions made on the US government
and how we operate
well the wet tech scandal shows some
problems with the system both in
government and in the financial
structure of the United States wet tech
was essentially two small-time con
artists in the South Bronx who parlayed
a little machine shaft into a hundred
million dollar a year New York Stock
Exchange company when wet tough collapse
in 1986 the taxpayers of the United
States were out more than a hundred
million dollars investors had invested
more than 160 million dollars in
worthless securities so there seemed to
be some problems both in the way the
program by which wet tech received its
federal contracts are administered also
in a way our securities markets are
regulated who would the two men two men
were John maryada a man of Puerto Rican
heritage who grew up in Spanish Harlem
and Fred Neuberger a Romanian immigrant
who came to the United States in 1947
mister maryada was the minority the
so-called minority owner that enabled
wet tech to qualify for a special
program called aid a that set aside
contracts for minority owned enterprises
in actuality he did not own the required
51% of the company as required by the
regulations he told the government he'll
own two-thirds of wet tech when in fact
he and mr. Neuberger each had a 50/50
sweat where are these two men today
they're both in federal prison mr.
Marriott is serving eight years at
Allenwood in Pennsylvania and mr.
Neuberger is serving
two plus years in Danbury Connecticut
where I'm told he's running the machine
shop how many public officials were
affected by this there were more than a
dozen public officials who were drawn
into the wet tech web including two
members of Congress who have been
convicted a regional administrator of
the Small Business Administration and a
number of Reagan White House aides were
also implicated in the scandal one man
though did go through the process was
convicted than it was overturned let
nafse occur how did that happen that's
correct
mr. Knapp Seeger had worked in the White
House in the office of political affairs
he left in early 1982 and set up a
consulting business one of his first
clients if not his first client was wet
tech he went back to his contacts in the
White House a short time later in
particular ad me so at that point was
counsel to the president and urged mr.
Meese to award a contract to wet tech
this was in violation of a requirement
that you wait one year prior to lobbying
your former agency mr. Knox eager was
convicted of illegal lobbying that
conviction was subsequently overturned
on the grounds that he did not knowingly
violate the law when he lobbied mr.
Meese our viewers know two men
particularly well mario biaggi who is
pictured right here and Congressman
Robert Garcia what happened to this man
Mr Biaggi was tried convicted and
sentenced to eight years in prison for
his dealings with wet tech which
included extorting 1.8 million dollars
worth of stock from the company and
congressman Garcia from the Bronx was
convicted in connection with his
dealings with wet tech and he is to be
sentenced January 5th of 1990 he still
holds his congressional
there's a picture of the congressman
Garcia and his wife that's correct
what about Mario Yad you take him as an
example how did it happen
Mariya biaggi discovered in the late
1970s that wet tech was doing some
defense business in the bronx and he
took a somewhat proprietary interest in
wet tech and came to Wedd tech and took
a tour of the plant it was somewhat
surprising because it was not in his
immediate congressional district but was
adjacent to his congressional district
and at the end of the tour he made a
pitch that wet tech would be well
advised to retain the services of a law
firm that he was in with a fellow named
Bernard Erlich and that he and Erlich
could help get wet tech contracts new
burger and maryada did not agree on much
but they did agree that it would be good
to have a powerful friend
like Mario biaggi they subsequently
retained the AG's law firm for at first
10,000 later $20,000 a year Berio biaggi
used his influence in Washington and
talked to people like congressman Joe
Addabbo senator D'Amato and others in an
effort to help wet ticket defense
contracts the quid pro quo or the
illegality came at a time when wet tech
went public with an offering of
securities and at that point
mario Biaggi demanded a huge block of
stock in the company which after much
discussion the wet tech officers agreed
to give him the huge block of stock was
concealed under the name of Mary OB
Ozzy's son Richard who was also
convicted in connection with wet Tex
Mario Biaggi today is where he's serving
a prison sentence in Texas for a
unrelated criminal case he's been
sentenced but not yet serving time for
his web tech conviction lessons learned
from the whole wet tech affair well
there's a few one is that the program
that wet tech benefited from the so
called a day program was essentially a
recipe for scandal that setting aside
these huge government contracts on a
no-bid non-competitive basis was like
leaving a bag of money on the street and
waiting for someone to come scoop it up
why did they have this no-bid set-aside
it was a Great Society program that was
started in the late 1960s in response to
the race riots of the late 60s as an
effort to build up minority Enterprise
certainly a laudable goal the Democrats
liked it because they took a view of an
activist government helping minority
entrepreneurs the Republicans liked it
because it implied bootstrap self help
but as in the HUD scandal what we see is
most of the money not going to the
minority entrepreneurs and their workers
but to the well-heeled consultants who
broker the contracts between the
government and the recipients second
lesson second lesson is there's a
problem with the way our financial
securities are structured and regulated
in this country wet tech though the
company was a sham from the start never
was a company in the sense of having
real profits and losses but was simply a
pyramid scheme where to keep the scam
going the web tech executives
consistently had to get more and more
contracts and if they couldn't steal
from the government they would steal
from investors by selling worthless
securities their books and records were
audited by two big eight accounting
firms they had a major Wall Street
invest
banker selling their securities these
their registration statements with the
Securities and Exchange Commission were
reviewed by two prominent Wall Street
law firms but none of these
professionals blew the whistle and the
reason is I don't think the incentives
were there that if the accountants or
the investment bankers or the lawyers
had blown the whistle and web tech had
collapsed they would not have received
their fees but by not blowing the
whistle by papering over the problems
they received their fees they had a
happy client so that's the way the
system is set up it's just keep your
client happy not to protect the
investing public and a lot of people I'm
sure watching this program may well have
been told by their brokers to go by wet
tech stock go by wet tech bonds these
people lost all their money will go to
the phones in about four minutes our
special guest is William Sternberg he's
the co-author of the book feeding frenzy
with Matthew Harrison jr. who is he Matt
Harrison took a job at wet tech in late
1986 as a vice president for
administration when the company
collapsed a few months later they needed
someone certifiably honest to try to
pick up the pieces salvage what was left
and recoup the looted assets for
creditors Matt was selected to continue
in that post and we wrote the book
together we have phone lines open if you
want to participate with William
Sternberg we're talking about the wet
tech case and what went into a book that
was written about that whole episode you
were originally with cranes New York
business you're originally from Brooklyn
Brooklyn New York you now live here in
Washington with the Thompson newspapers
118 newspapers across the country why a
book this was one of those stories that
the more I discovered the more I learned
the more I felt that a newspaper or
magazine article did not do justice to
the huge cast of characters and the huge
array of scams that were involved I had
started cover
we´d tech for cranes
New York business in early 86 before
anyone had heard of wet tech had got up
there to do a feature story about what
was supposedly the shining star of the
minority set-aside program and interview
mr. maryada who President Reagan had
called a hero for the 80s and in fact
mr. maryada had been to a cabinet
meeting at the White House in which he
sang the praises of wet tech and
President Reagan praised both the
company and its accomplishments did the
president ever comment on this case
after it became public he did not
continue to call mr. maryada a hero for
the 80s as he did Oliver North ed Meese
ed Meese helped wet tech get its first
and most important contract as a result
of insistent lobbying from his good
friend San Francisco lawyer by the name
of Robert Wallach and an independent
counsel found that mr. Meese did not
commit any criminal wrongdoing in
connection with wet tech but a
prosecutor in New York later said that
Lisa's conduct in relation to wet tech
was sleazy
and I would not quibble with that
assessment why do you say sleazy in 1981
the White House counsel's office had
issued guidelines to people working in
the White House saying they should not
become personally involved with any
federal contracts and with they in which
they their relatives or their friends
had a financial interest this did not
dissuade mr. Meese from becoming
involved with wet tech on the entreaties
of his close friend a bob Wallach later
on mr. Meese would intervene in an
effort to get an important loan
subordination from the Commerce
Department for wet tech and after the
wet tech investigation broke and mr.
Meese was Attorney General mr. Wallach
showed up at his hotel room in New York
where me said given a speech and the two
men two of the wet tech executives have
testified that right about this time
they each offered while like a hundred
thousand dollars if he could keep them
out of jail and kill the Justice
Department investigation
shortly after this offer was allegedly
made Bob Wallach shows up the dead mises
hotel room in New York
the two men talk privately behind closed
doors for approximately half an hour
there's only two people who know what
was said at that meeting Bob wallak is
where mr. Wallach has been convicted of
racketeering in connection with the wet
tech case he's been sentenced to six
years he's appealing that conviction
Nassau County New York go ahead please
yes I my original question was incorrect
I was wondering why mr. biaggi
what is the delay in serving his full
sentence there's really no delay other
than the normal legal process he's
appealing his web tech conviction and
he's been he will not officially start
serving his wet tech time until that
appeal is complete but as I said he's
already serving time in Texas for his
dealings with coastal dry dock another
defense contractor that was based in
Brooklyn New York next call go ahead
please where you calling from
and I'd like to ask the author whether
as a matter of fact he feels that as in
other cases at HUD and other things that
the people as a matter of fact that were
close to the Reagan administration for
some reason either don't get convicted
or as a matter of fact are get their
appeal or get their conviction
overturned and and does he feel that
this is another case or something like
that no I don't see it that way
one thing that wet tech showed was that
greed knows no party lines and in the
course of the scandal it was either
portrayed
by the Democrats as a Reagan White House
scandal it was portrayed by the
Republicans as a democratic
congressional scandal when in fact
people from both parties were allowing
their palms to be greased by the crooks
at wet tech so I don't think the
Republicans or the Reagan people have
gotten off any easier than have the
Democrats in this case mr. Bob Seger was
convicted but that conviction was
overturned on legal grounds certainly
mr. Wallick faces a very long time in
prison and mr. Peter neg Lea who was a
Reagan administrative important
appointee in New York also is serving a
prison term for his wet tech dealings
caller where are you calling from please
Holly North Carolina
all right ahead you're on the air I was
hearing the beginning of your comments
and he said that the two big 8 firms
failed to blow the whistle on some of
the activities of wet wet tech I was
wondering are you confident to comment
on the the audit work of accountants and
are those big 8 firms involved in in any
legal proceedings because of wet tech
thank you there are some there is civil
litigation against the two firms that
audited wet textbook books by the people
who lost money as a result of relying on
those audits so they do face exposure to
that regard we have lines open for our
special guest this morning bill
Sternberg talking about the wet tech
case Trenton New Jersey go ahead please
[Music]
generally among people who were looking
for businesses who would come to me they
understood the benefits to be got by
them by finding a minority person to
front their business
and that also applied to Cedars and to
the SBA and I felt I was young and I I
felt sometimes that I was helping
minority people by finding backers for
them because they were not experienced
business people but you know looking
back I feel that no I later moved into
larger areas and I understand the
corruption on Wall Street because I
thought in the small businesses and I
still have a large business I think the
entire business community in the
interstates well I saw for many many
years is corrupt and it and it created
the environment and webcampus West West
web tech is just an example I always
wondered why I'm not a broker anymore
exactly okay thanks your reaction well
what tech certainly was not the only
minority business scam I would say
however it was the most spectacular of
the a day scams by the time it collapsed
wet tech had received some four hundred
ninety four million dollars in
government contracts and they were being
awarded contracts to build important
national security related components
small engines for the army pontoons for
the Navy and because of wet Texan
confidence and corruption when the rapid
deployment force sailed in the mid-80s
they needed these pontoons in order to
get men and materiel from ship to shore
in the case of a crisis well they did
not have these pontoons because wet tech
was not producing them on time or
properly is there anything there today
at were the wet tech headquarters used
to be just a shell virtually all of the
assets have been sold off efforts to
salvage what was left of wet tech were
unsuccessful the company turned out to
be rotten from the core was so far
behind and it's contracts that no one
could could pick up the pieces so
virtually
all the assets which at its peak
stretched from South Bronx
to Upper Michigan to Israel virtually
nothing is left Watertown New York I'm
sorry San Diego California go ahead
please I'd like to know why the defense
contract audit agency didn't pick up on
this cam as they were reviewing the
books of Witek it's a very good question
as it turned out some of the mid-level
bureaucrats at the defense contract
administration did realize that wet tech
was not producing anywhere near to the
rate and cost at which they were
supposed to be producing we came across
one case where a auditor for DCA a
calculated that wet tech would require
370 it would cost wet tech at the rate
they were going 370 million dollars to
complete a 70 million dollar contract on
which they were working what happened
was the bureaucrats at DCAA who
discovered this were overruled by their
political masters who did not want to
hear the truth about wet tech but in
fact had set up wed tech as the model
minority enterprise that was
revitalizing the south bronx and in many
cases not incidentally paying them large
fees on the side so what happened was
the auditors were simply overruled by
their political masters new book in your
bookstores called the inside story of
wet tech the feeding frenzy our guest
bill Sternberg to co-author Watertown
New York now go ahead please it's it's
apparent that what's at the bottom of
all this is agreed by our public
officials and as such don't you think of
federal Ethics Commission a composed of
non-political people should be set up to
pass on Congress and all administration
officials no matter what the politics
as they say you can't legislate morality
whether a commission can do it any
better I'm not certain Congress has its
own ethics procedures which have worked
reasonably well in the case of members
of Congress involved in wet tech
certainly the executive branch needs
looking at there were some reforms
passed in the wake of the wet tech
scandal
for example anyone who lobbies now and
an executive branch agency on behalf of
a defense contractor or other private
interests now has to disclose that
information which was not the case when
these people were lobbying for wet tech
or for HUD for that matter in New York
there with you why do you I notice that
in the on the jacket here though the
fellow who wrote the long gray line Rick
Atkinson says nice things about this
book why are you interested in the long
gray line as it turns out Matt Harrison
is one of the heroes of the long gray
line that was a member of the West Point
class of 1966 which is featured in
direct Atkinson's book that went to
Vietnam was highly decorated in Vietnam
put in his 20 years with the army as it
turned out he was looking for a private
sector job when he got out of the Army
and decided rather than go with a major
defense contractor where he would just
be one more piece of a big apparatus
that he was looking for a small
entrepreneurial company where he could
be make a difference and being somewhat
naive and idealistic Matt felt that a
minority company that was helping people
in the South Bronx would would be a
perfect opportunity
for him and to his great shock and
dismay when he got inside wet tech it
soon collapsed and he discovered that
the company was rotten to the core and
he had not made a wise career decision
and Matt's experiences with wet tech
actually I recounted well in mr.
atkinson's book and it also in the
beginning of this book he writes a
little prologue to how he got into what
in the first place Seattle Washington go
ahead please anymore it's too
distracting with all those books behind
you I understand that's been said before
mr. Steinberg are you ready to do
another book I'm looking for a co-author
what do you want to write about dollar
and I got why do you want to write about
the Pentagon well I have not been
following that as closely as I did wet
tech there have been a number of
indictments and there were some recent
fleas in that case but I'm not familiar
with the current status of ill wind
winston-salem North Carolina go ahead
please yeah I have a couple of things
I'd like to ask first of all you
mentioned that the man who ran wet tech
was indicted for racketeering I was
wondering if they used the RICO Act to
grab all this guy's possessions like
they do these drug lords and things like
that because it seems that the RICO Act
is being used in as being used
discriminately just against regular
criminal types and people who have
political ties are involved in all these
money games seem to slip out of the net
and they never get their assets seized
another point I'd like to make is don't
you think that the attorney general's
office should be an elected office
instead of an appointed one since it's
been used or missed you misused for the
last eight ten twelve fourteen I don't
know how many years all right sir thanks
Bill Steinberg yes in the case of the
racketeering law that for for the
corrupt wet tech executive
as part of their plea bargain the deal
was they would not be convicted under
Rico so Rico was used in that case as a
threat to get them to plead guilty and
cooperate with the government and
testify against various public officials
who they bribed a number of the public
officials and mr. Wallach were
prosecuted under the RICO law in terms
of the wet tech executives because they
were not indicted or convicted under
Rico during the time prior to their
sentencing they continued to live high
on the hog they went to Atlantic City
they took expensive vacations they
bought furs and jewelry and maintained a
pretty good lifestyle because their
assets were not seized in the case of
the Attorney General rather than making
it an elected office perhaps the Senate
ought to use better discretion and
tougher standards in who they confirm as
Attorney General and they could clear to
the White House that someone needs to be
better qualified than say ed Meese was
as a longtime friend and aide to Ronald
Reagan Huntington New York go ahead
please as a resident New York I find
this disgusting horrible I wondering why
no more no publicity has been really
forthcoming about your book and why all
these lobbying organizations are allowed
to get away with all of these insanities
that keep going on and why though you
speak out very freely
the average American voter really can't
do anything about this thank you
well the average American voter can
demand high ethical standards of their
elected representatives and vote out of
office those who they feel do not
exemplify those standard
Seattle Washington again go ahead please
yes in the light of the SNL
multibillion-dollar scandal and the HUD
situation and what you described with
wet tech I believe the mass media should
be very ashamed of itself for the
hounding and all the attention given to
for instance Jim Baker and Swaggart
which was the mass media was focusing on
and not paying any attention Baker
basically whatever money they get is
what somebody wanted to give wherever
whereas the S&L stuff and the HUD stuff
involves taxpayer money that we are
compelled to give and I'd appreciate it
if the mass media would concern itself
more with these multibillion-dollar
fight scandals and not worry too much
about the con artists that take it from
people that feel like giving it alright
thank you does he have a point well he
has a point in the sense that everyone
in the country lost loses money as a
result of something like HUD or wet tech
or SNL in the case of Jim Baker was
people who were contributing to him who
were being fleeced that's not to defend
his conduct in any way certainly there
was no shortage of scandals during the
1980s and whether that has diminished
our capacity for moral outrage remains
to be seen is it harder to get but we we
had been billing wet tech as the biggest
financial scandal in government since
teapot dome that has been far eclipsed
if you include the Savings and Loan
scandal in total is it harder to get the
story told that you want to tell than it
is to tell the Jim and Tammy Faye Bakker
story I'd have to ask the author of the
recent book on that scandal what
difficulties he involved I mean at least
we had the benefit of being able to
obtain a lot of documents under the
Freedom of Information Act because wet
tech was dealing with government
agencies and government programs so
there were certain documents available
to us that were how
full there was also a Senate
investigation the transcript of which
and all the investigative documents were
available to us in addition a special
prosecutor investigated at least and his
papers are slowly being released by the
National Archives so in the sense it is
easier to investigate a public scandal
than a private one
Langhorne Pennsylvania you're next yes I
was a government employee for many years
and got involved with a company that was
a phony small business was backed by a
big business and also was involved with
a program that government implemented to
prevent fraud waste and mismanagement
which was kind of an academic drill that
was conducted
I personally unearthed the two and a
half million dollar fraudulent invoicing
situation that had gone on for three or
four years and turned over hard evidence
to the Naval Investigative Service who
in turn botched the investigation and
whitewashed the whole situation I guess
my question essentially is what lesson
has been learned as a result of the wet
tech situation and what programs are
being implemented to prevent any
reoccurrence thank you there was a
reform of the a day law designed to
prevent future wet Tech's large
contracts will no longer be on an out no
bid non-competitive basis there which
tends to attract political influence
peddling now the large a day contracts
will be on a competitive basis among
minority firms and there are a number of
other reforms that were undertaken as I
said earlier you still can't legislate
morality so it remains to be seen how
effective those will be there have also
been some reforms that have been
undertaken to restrict lobbying or at
least fuller disclosure of lobbying of
federal officials however nothing has
been done as far as I've seen to try to
deal with the financial aspect of the
web tech scandal where you've got
auditors who found forged invoices like
the caller did I mean these the
troubling thing about wet tech is these
were not criminal masterminds these were
basically small-time garden-variety
crooks they're scams were not
particularly clever or inventive the
auditors found them very quickly the way
wet tech dealt with it was simply to buy
off the auditors and hire them for wet
tech at salaries far exceeding what they
were receiving at the accounting firms
New York City go ahead please yeah you
mentioned D'Amato while ago in
connection with this al D'Amato senator
yes from New York because he's also
isn't he being investigated something to
do with the hood to and also it seems to
me that there's a same thing happening
over and over again about you know you
make a rule they go around it look at
HUD has all kind of rules right and then
they got around all this it's all that
you answer yeah senator D'Amato well if
I can tell a little story when I first
went to Wed Tech mr. Neuberger who was
the vice chairman said that the
politicians have really helped the
company and I asked him well who's been
the most helpful and he mentioned
congressman Biaggi congressman Garcia
Congressman Addabbo and Senator D'Amato
Biaggi and Garcia have been convicted in
the wet tech case Addabbo was dead-and
D'Amato is now being investigated by the
Senate Ethics Committee both for HUD and
his dealings with wet tech al D'Amato
was a cheerleader for wet tech
throughout his first term from 1981
through 1986 said a number of laudatory
things about the company helped lobby to
get them contracts and he received
eleven thousand dollars in legal
campaign contributions from wet tech
executives one former wet
executive has testified that wet tech
funneled another 30,000 in illegal
contributions to Senator D'Amato D'Amato
has denied any knowledge of the illegal
contributions and you may have a case
here with senator Lovato similar to that
of the so-called Keating five with the
S&L scandal whereby although he may have
not done anything illegal in connection
with wet tech his support of wet tech
contrary to all facts and evidence ended
up costing the taxpayers of this country
tens of millions of dollars Albuquerque
New Mexico you're on with Bill Sternberg
go ahead please you mentioned mr. walk I
think he was the same individual was
involved in arranging with mr. Meese to
pay extortion money or protection money
to Israel not to blow up a potential oil
pipeline through the Middle East and
also it seems you also mentioned Israel
being Robin wet tech it seems every time
there's a scandal whether it's selling
arms to Iran or transferring nuclear
technology and to South Africa or
training hitman and Colombia for drug
lords Israel's involvement please
explain Israel's involvement in this
case the only Israeli involvement in wet
tech was that wet tech purchased a
subsidiary in Israel to make castings
for its engines
norther comment Fort Lauderdale Florida
go ahead please yes I was wondering if
anybody had suggested that these
politicians and public officials be
charged with treason in their dealings
and scams that you've been talking about
today since they are in fact betraying
the public and the taxpayers and getting
away pretty much with anything they
please reason that sounds a little
extreme I think the racketeering laws
would be sufficient you ask you after
you spent how much time you spend alone
I had covered wet tech for approximately
two years for cranes I spent one year
full-time on the book after the book was
written and now since you've seen a
number of people convicted and even go
to jail are there any in your opinion
that got away there are some of the
smaller fish who got away as one
prosecutor told me she could have spent
the rest of her life
prosecuting people who were connected to
wet tech wet tech new one and one
business strategy only and that was to
pay people off and they paid everyone
off ranging from people in the white
house to the utility inspectors who
checked their plants did they try to pay
you off not directly but and in
retrospect the first time I went to wet
tech the I have scheduled an interview
with mr. Neuberger the vice chairman he
told me that he couldn't talk to me at
the moment because wet tech was in the
registration period for a stock offering
and under SEC regulations he wasn't
allowed to talk about the company well I
grumbled something about I wish he had
told me that before I had flown up from
Washington to do the interview and at
that point he said well don't worry
about it pal will pay for you to come up
next time and being wary of accepting
anything of value from people I write
about I declined at the time I saw the
offer is quite innocent but in
retrospect I think he was probably
trying to pay me off just like they paid
everyone else off last call Westchester
in New York above New York City go ahead
please yes I originally wanted to talk
earlier when mr. Stockwell is on but I
think I can apply it here and this is in
relation to a little more discussion one
on one you know earlier when you had the
government official art I've seen him on
I've seen him before and he's been on
crossfire however I've never seen a
one-on-one discussion in other words
having a serious discussion with the
people that are that are having problems
with your opinions however besides that
I'd like to also talk about the billion
dollar scandal which well we can assume
it's a billion dollar scandal
however in in law enforcement it's
common knowledge that you only catch a
certain percentage of the criminals so
therefore I think we can assume that
there's multi-multi amount of billions
of dollars that simply are not caught in
other scandals that simply aren't you
know taken in investigation
let's ask our our guest if he thinks
that there are a lot of those they're
out there similar situations that people
just aren't getting caught
there probably are as I said I think wet
tech was probably the most spectacular
scam in the a day program it would be
hard to imagine a bigger scandal than
wet tech in the 8 a program where you
had a half a New York Stock Exchange
company that had received a half a
billion dollars in federal contracts
that really was nothing more than a sham
but who are the good it's not a very
fair question who the good guys I mean
who are the people out there that did a
good job and bringing all this stuff out
in the public
there was an investigator with the
office of labor racketeering u.s.
department of labor who did an excellent
job in cracking the wet tech case there
was a assistant US attorney who worked
for Rudy Giuliani the crusading
prosecutor in the Southern District of
New York who recently lost the New York
City mayoral race who did an excellent
job named her name is Mary Shannon the
Labor Department investigators name was
Steve Kazu they both worked together and
helped crack the Wed Tech case it was
some excellent investigative reporting
done specifically by the New York Daily
News and the New York Times and there
were some federal bureaucrats who tried
to stand up to wet tech for tax the tax
protect the taxpayers money
but ended up losing their jobs as a
result got 10 seconds what did you think
over all the sentences people got for
their crimes generally fair however I
thought the wet tech crooks who stole
some 15 million dollars and lived high
off the hog got off too easily bill
Sternberg has been our guest originally
from Brooklyn New York currently the
news editor in the Washington bureau of
Thompson newspapers co-author of the
book feeding frenzy with Matthew
Harrison thank you for joining us thank
you thanks for joining us have a good
day
if you have further questions or
comments for our guests you can write to
William Sternberg in care of Henry Holt
& Company at 1:15 West 18th Street in
New York the zip code is 1 0 0 1 1 and
we'd like to remind our viewers that the
topic for our callin program this
evening at 6:30 Eastern time will be
money and politics but coming up next a
forum focusing on the Ford presidency
[Music]
this week on book notes I find that
people a couple people that I've